okay so now let's get to the uh
reaction from donald trump to this just
blockbuster scandal where donald trump
is accused
not just of wanting to collude with
ukraine
for his benefit in the 2020 election but
of allegedly
withholding 250 million dollars in aid
unless ukraine smears joe biden to help
trump
in 2020. we already looked at what
trump's
tv lawyer rudy giuliani said about this
he went on chris cuomo and he said
i never had ukraine do anything about
biden then immediately said
of course i asked ukraine to investigate
joe biden and when
chris cuomo calls him out for it he says
i never denied
saying that i talked to ukraine about
joe biden that was all within like 35
seconds okay we talked about that
earlier in the show
we now are getting to video of a visibly
red and disheveled looking donald trump
particularly red and disheveled
here is trump with of course a
helicopter in the background
making it extremely difficult to hear
anything anybody is saying
and trump admits that yes the topic of
joe biden
did come up during the me during the
phone call
with the ukrainian president back in
july that part is clear
and then of course it's just details
take a look at this we had a great
conversation uh
the conversation i had was
largely congratulatory was largely
corruption all of the corruption
taking place was largely the fact that
we don't want our people
like vice president biden and his son
creating to the corruption already in
the ukraine and ukraine uh ukraine's got
a lot of problems he
the new president is saying that he's
going to be able
to rid the country of corruption and i
said that would be a great thing
we had a great conversation we had a
conversation on many things in fact
i believe ukraine put out a statement
yesterday
say that we covered many different
topics it was a warm and friendly
conversation
we backed i backed ukraine from the
beginning
so there trump says yeah we did talk
about
joe biden we talked about how people
like joe biden and his son
are bad and they should be kept out of
power which is of course
not a denial of exactly what it is that
is being reported trump just not going
far enough in admitting
the full details of that the report was
biden was discussed
and that part is of course true the next
question is
are the details about not agreeing to a
white house meeting with the ukrainian
president
and withholding 250 million in military
aid because ukraine
has not yet smeared biden is that part
true but we've got part one which is
trump admits biden did come up during
that phone call
now here's another clip this is more
yelling over the chopper
trump asked if rudy giuliani is involved
here
and trump says he would love to have
rudy giuliani
involved and of course once again
another point is confirmed
we suspected that rudy giuliani was
involved
rudy giuliani more recently on chris
cuomo's program on cnn
after denying that he was involved in
talking to ukraine about biden
admits it and here is donald trump
saying it would be great if rudy
giuliani was involved
giuliani talk to congress
oh i would have no problem with rudy's a
very straight shooter
and rudy wants to see the same thing as
a lot of other people with respect to
ukraine
ukraine has had a tremendous corruption
problem
somehow they were involved in a lot of
different things that took place in our
country
and hopefully it could be straightened
out and i will say
the new president he had a very good
talk
the new president got elected based on
the fact that he would end corruption
that was probably his number one thing
mr president then trump just repeats
listen to me like a crazy person and
then concocts
some cockamamie conspiracy theory about
joe biden
while still defending the phone call
with the ukrainian president listen to
me
listen listen
listen to me i assume many people
are on the line i know that before and
make the call on that but you have
intelligence agencies everybody
listening
that call was a great goal it was a
perfect call a perfect call
what wasn't perfect is the horrible
thing that joe biden said
and now he made a lie what he said he
never spoke to his son
i mean give me a break he's already said
he spoke to his son
and now he said yesterday very firmly
are you going right now
of course you spoke to your son so he
made the mistake of saying
he never spoke to his son he spoke to
his son but more importantly
what he said about the billions of
dollars that he wouldn't give them
unless they fired the prosecutor and
then he bragged about how they fired the
prosecutor
and they got the money
these are the rantings of a disheveled
madman it i i'm not trying to make fun
of anyone when i say this
but trump is not only now sounding like
the guy
on the subway platform yelling at you
about the fifth coming of zeus or
something while urinating on the third
rail
trump is also looking like that guy and
here he is with more conspiracy theories
saying biden china
sell out something something
well not only ukraine take a look at
china they took a tremendous amount of
money out of china
now if they ever took over a china
negotiation he would sell us
out look at all the money he made in
china the sun he knew nothing
the sun is the stiff he knew nothing and
he's making hundreds of thousands and
millions of dollars
and he did the same thing in ukraine he
knows nothing
this is a very dishonest thing that joe
biden did and then he said he never
spoke to his son
does anybody believe that one so this is
the new corruption this is the new
treason this is the new bribery
and we are all just sort of getting used
to it and just
looking at trump in this video you can
tell that he's not well
never mind you know listening to the
absolutely
ridiculous things that he's saying and
uh we've gotten used to it you look
online you look at the comments
on these videos and it's overwhelmingly
things from left and right
uh yeah this is sort of crazy but this
is just
trump uh is it drugs we don't know is it
that this is what shame looks like we
know we say donald trump doesn't really
seem to be able to feel shame maybe he
is able to feel
shame and this is what he looks like and
sounds like when he's feeling shame that
this has gone public i don't know the
answer but as far as
you know i i do think that these
conspiracy theories about joe biden
are becoming prominent enough that we
probably want to just do a little bit of
a debunking of them and of course i know
that there are people who will say david
how are you now a biden supporter
uh when we talk about this but tomorrow
i think it's important we don't even
know who's going to be the democratic
nominee and i want it to be someone
actually progressive compared to joe
biden who's a center-left democrat
but we can't let these conspiracy
theories about joe biden gain momentum
and gain
steam so probably on tomorrow's show if
not wednesdays
i will outline exactly what the
allegations are here against joe biden
and we will thoroughly debunk them
impeachment
is the word of the day the first step of
the impeachment process of donald trump
has started and
donald trump is flying off the rails as
a result we will talk about all of this
this is an impeachment inquiry important
word a lot of people
very clearly not understanding the full
process and why would you
impeachment of presidents is not a
common thing this was announced
yesterday by the speaker of the house
nancy pelosi let's take a look
the actions of the trump presidency
revealed a dishonorable fact
of the president's betrayal of his oath
of office
betrayal of our national security and
betrayal of the integrity
of our elections therefore today
i'm announcing the house of
representatives moving forward with an
official
impeachment inquiry i'm directing our
six committees to proceed with their
investigations
under that umbrella so there's confusion
about what this
is and what this is not impeachment is a
long process there are three primary
steps and these
can be subdivided into even really 10 or
12 different steps but the generality
the three primary
phases are an impeachment inquiry
if the inquiry leads the inquirers
to decide that actually impeaching the
president
via a trial is appropriate you go to an
impeachment trial
by the house of representatives and
after that phase is complete
phase two you go to phase three which is
a vote in the senate as to whether or
not to convict the president
and thus remove them from office now
this is not going to
lead to a conviction of donald trump in
the senate and thus the removal of
donald trump
the senate is controlled by republicans
we don't have to go through the details
but as you
know if you've been following politics
for the last couple of years with some
very limited exceptions republicans are
not interested
willing or even remotely considering
removing this president from office so
the process that democrats will now
follow
must be strategic and it must be thought
out because donald trump
will try and he is already trying you
will see his tweets momentarily
to turn this around into he's the victim
he's a martyr just doing great things
for the united states
and these witch-hunt democrats won't let
him just make america great again so
this the the goal here is hurt trump in
2020
because the impeachment process is not
going to remove donald trump
so that then becomes a question of are
we confident that democrats can carry
this out in the right way
is there going to be infighting among
democrats around this
such that it will become a distraction
we already saw there's this a
member of congress from hawaii who is
running for president named tulsi
gabbard she says she's against what
nancy pelosi is doing are we going to
see conflict within the democratic party
that will uh allow donald trump to take
advantage of this in some way
uh last night on i did a live stream on
youtube uh
about the breaking impeachment news and
there were a lot of people who were
saying david you know this talk of
impeachment backfiring
that's a republican talking point no no
no i'm not talking about
the process backfiring in so far as
the impeachment inquiry is not warranted
on the substance donald trump clearly
deserves
at minimum an impeachment inquiry will
not put the cart before the horse
depending on what the inquiry finds we
can talk about whether
the impeachment trial is the next step
that's not what i mean when i say
backfire what i mean by backfire
is that if democrats bungle the process
if democrats bungle the pr around this
it will allow donald trump
to paint himself successfully as the
victim martyr
and it will not hurt him in 2020.
i've been getting emails from people
saying david it's over for trump
trump needs to resign and set up mike
mike pence to pardon him
the way that richard nixon did number
one it's unlikely that donald trump's
ego
would allow that to happen but i don't
think it's necessary donald trump is not
going to be convicted on impeachment by
a republican-controlled senate
before january of 2021 which is when the
next
congress and president would be sworn in
so there are two ways that this can go
given that trump won't be removed before
the election number one
this doesn't work because americans get
exhausted by 14 months of it leader
however many months i guess about 13
months
leading up to the election and it ends
up helping donald trump that's one way
the other way it can go is that the
inquiry reveals the president's
wrongdoing in such
uh an an uncontestable way to such a
degree
that it destroys trump and republicans
in the 2020 election when we go back to
bill clinton
people like to remind me that bill
clinton's approval went up during
impeachment but remember number one bill
clinton didn't try to interfere
number two bill clinton had a strong
economy and number three
what was at issue were lies about an
affair donald trump
has engaged in borderline traitorous
behavior and of course
donald trump is absolutely losing it on
twitter which is an indication
that he is not going to allow this
process to play out calmly
in the way that bill clinton did i've
been telling you for years
if impeachment starts what we've seen on
twitter so far by donald trump will be
nothing compared to what we will see
and it's already happening donald trump
starting to wind up yesterday tweeting
such an important day at the united
nations so much work and so much success
and the democrats purposely had to ruin
and demean it with more breaking news
witch-hunt garbage
so bad for our country later tweeting
presidential harassment in all caps
and then this morning scaling it up even
more donald trump tweeting quote there
has been no president
in the history of our capital c country
who has been treated so badly as i have
the democrats are frozen with hatred and
fear they get nothing done
this should never be allowed to happen
to another president
witch hunt so remember trump won't be
removed by this impeachment
because once again republicans control
the senate
but donald trump is already losing it
if there were to be i mean listen
imagine
if donald trump were to be convicted and
removed by the senate imagine the level
of violence that we would see happening
from trumpists uh i i would actually
consider staying away from public places
i really would but in the end that's not
going to happen
and the conversation has been about is
the president
going to be removed and what is the
strategy on that basis
the real question is should the
president be impeached
given what we know and the answer is as
far as an impeachment inquiry
obviously yes so this inquiry is the
first step
and it is the correct step there is no
question about it the political strategy
around it
is important given that the senate is
not going to vote to convict
but on the facts obviously
there is a a completely uh there's a
completely obvious case for why this
impeachment inquiry is now starting
and it's not only donald trump who's
flipping out it's also rudy giuliani
let's talk about that next
donald trump has unfortunately for
americans
once again completely embarrassed
himself and by extension
embarrassed the united states on the
world stage at yesterday's speech that
he gave in front of the
united nations general assembly now as a
speech
it was horrendous extremely low energy
it was that mumbling stumbling trump
that often appears to be coming down
from uppers as i've mentioned before
that showed up to yesterday's speech now
hilariously
there were actually some journalistic
descriptions of the speech
that called it sober and respectful
which are the most polite possible words
that you can assign
to downer trump the version of trump
that shows up
when he is in that coming down from
uppers sort of mode that we've
identified before
now of course donald trump used the
teleprompter which also helps to keep
trump in that low energy mode something
remember he made fun of barack obama
for using when barack obama was
president it turns out i guess
that using a teleprompter and being able
to read
leads to far better speeches than using
a teleprompter and struggling to read
which is what donald trump
does every single time he uses that
prompter but it wasn't just the style of
trump's speech
that was atrocious the content of the
speech was disgusting as well
this was one of the most nationalist
speeches
that donald trump has given criticizing
countries that in his view treat the us
unfairly
talking about being against globalism
and for patriotism which is once again
this tired anti-semitic trope
throwing in some awkwardly worded
deference to things like
treating people well and valuing
differences which we have
no evidence that actually suggests trump
believes or even thinks
is important uh and once again
downer trump is the guy that showed up
this is the one that appears to be
coming down from uppers
slurring doing the sh thing when s's
exist in words appearing to chew on his
own teeth
stopping looking confused at the words
on the teleprompter take a look
the world fully expects that the chinese
government will honor its
binding treaty it is time for iran's
leaders to step
forward america is ready to embrace
friendship
with all who genuinely seek
peace the receiving countries are
overburdened with more migrants than
they can
responsibly accept nations that empower
women are much
wealthier safer
and much more politically
stable americans will never
fire or tire
in our effort to defend and promote
freedom
liberty is only preserved
sovereignty is only secured
yesterday i was also pleased to host
leaders
for a discussion about an ironclad
american commitment
extraordinarily strange behavior i mean
just again
genuinely strange behavior that i've
heard no
reasonable explanation for so far let's
look
at another moment from the speech here
where donald trump does his
globalism bad patriotism good thing
a free world must embrace its national
foundations
it must not attempt to erase them
or replace them looking around
and all over this large
magnificent planet the truth is plain to
see
if you want freedom take pride in your
country
if you want democracy hold on to your
sovereignty
and if you want peace love your nation
wise leaders always put the good of
their own people
and their own country first
the future does not belong to globalists
the future belongs to patriots the
future belongs to sovereign and
independent nations
who protect their citizens respect their
neighbors
and honor the differences that make each
country
special and unique
is why we in the united states
have embarked on an exciting program of
national
renewal we're not globalists but we are
patriots now as i mentioned already
extremely low energy so energy solo
energy in fact that one of donald
trump's cabinet secretaries
slept through the speech we'll talk
about that
a little bit later but more importantly
looking awful
sounding awful and the content being
ridiculous
the entire criticizing globalists thing
has an ugly anti-semitic past whether or
not
donald trump knows that whether or not
donald trump is deliberately referencing
it for that reason but it's a dog
whistle for jews
that has been around for a very very
very long time
but it's important not to miss the
bigger picture here which is that the
united states
is increasingly not part of the serious
and
important conversations that world
leaders around the world
are having trying to solve some of the
big problems of our time the big picture
is that
donald trump's reference to an
anti-semitic trope
shouldn't be allowed to distract us from
an increasingly
cornered and backpedaling donald trump
on his excuses for why
he would withhold the hundreds of
million dollars in aid from ukraine
because he wanted them to smear joe
biden while suppressing a whistleblower
and
in the end it becomes difficult to even
figure out
which ridiculous public embarrassment or
crisis
is meant to be a distraction from some
other sometimes
even worse ridiculous public
embarrassment but
embarrassing himself on the world stage
is something that has become
unfortunately all too common under this
presidency i know that the trumpists
don't agree with me
and i know that they also don't care
what other countries think about trump
and in fact they become emboldened when
they hear
that other countries are not even
including trump in conversations about
climate change for for example other
countries are not even including trump
in conversations about how can we get
iran back into compliance with the iran
nuclear deal
particularly given that trump bailed on
the deal without iran having
actually broken any of the conditions of
that deal and
when we look at the coverage of
something like the u.n general assembly
here in the united states
we understandably have a very
trump-centric view either people who
love what trump did
or anybody who has a good head on their
shoulders and realizes the embarrassing
nature of what trump did
in other countries it's not just that
they are much more unanimous
in their understanding that what trump
said is ridiculous
it arguably even worse where it doesn't
even really matter
what donald trump is doing and saying
because other countries are increasingly
not even including the united states in
important conversations about so many of
the issues that are facing humanity
right now
and that's the real tragedy that it will
take a long time to undo
once donald trump is no longer president
you can tell tensions are running very
high
within donald trump's inner circle
because of the start of this impeachment
inquiry against him and donald trump's
lawyer rudy giuliani went on tv
yesterday
and absolutely lost it starting to call
the other guest
a [ __ ] and i get it everything is
coming crashing down
around the trump administration they are
panicked they are now planning to put
out
what is effectively the bar letter 2.0
i'll talk to you about that in the next
segment
uh with regard to the transcript of
trump's phone call with the ukrainian
president in july so i understand why
this is happening
check this out look at the abuse that
rudy giuliani
trump's lawyer hurls at his fellow guest
on fox news's laura ingraham program
the person rudy giuliani is attacking
here is chris hahn
who's a former aide to democratic
senator chuck schumer
clearly rudy is not pleased with him
take a look at this
irresponsibly please yeah well you
actually
usually say incredibly stupid things
you're a public figure
yeah and uh by the way do you have any
idea that the state
know what you're talking department
chris you don't know what you're talking
about idiot i do
the state no you don't you're just a
liar i wish you would stop
you lied i wish you would stop this dude
why don't you tell him why don't you
tell him to keep his mouth shut so we
can tell the truth yeah chris just let
rooney just keep your mind
okay he said now for a while rudy
giuliani was known for drinking
before going on evening television shows
that he would appear on and it was a big
problem for a while
people in the around trump are trying to
keep rudy giuliani on daytime shows
because he wouldn't be drinking before
those at least not not often
i don't know if that was a factor here
but yelling shut up [ __ ] the day your
client
formally becomes the target of an
impeachment inquiry does not exactly
scream
confident cooperation for the benefit of
your client does it
i don't know that shut up [ __ ] totally
clears the president as donald trump
often likes to say
so first of all i get it this is not
good for anyone
and everybody around donald trump is
panicking tensions are running extremely
high
the other thing is that rudy giuliani
could actually
end up being a far more sinister player
in all of this
than we've known up till now and i think
that in addition to an impeachment
inquiry into donald trump
rudy giuliani should be investigated
because rudy giuliani is the president's
personal attorney
and what he's doing is traveling all
around the world lobbying on behalf
of all sorts of different interests some
of them foreign interests rudy giuliani
was involved in
his uh lobbying ukraine to smear joe
biden that we know at this point
rudy's admitted it and uh trump has
admitted it
rudy giuliani was recently with romanian
leaders
criticizing anti-corruption efforts
going on
there and there are immediately
questions about who is rudy giuliani
speaking for when he does this stuff
does he speak for the president
does he speak for the state department
is he communicating
anything that is an official or a
pseudo-official position for the u.s
government
the government has clarified rudy does
not speak for them
but that actually raises even more
questions about who's paying rudy
giuliani for what he's doing
is he properly registered under farah
for the work that he is doing sometimes
in the interests of foreign governments
it's truly unheard of but that is the
name of the game here
all of this stuff is not okay the
ukraine stuff
the the money laundering alligator i
mean there's this long list of stuff
but is anybody going to be held
accountable for it because that has been
the trump experiment
yeah this stuff is not okay but are they
going to do anything to us and so far
the system has not actually dealt with
what the president's administration has
been willing to do and unless that
changes
they are getting away with all of it let
me know what you think
about all of this the wisdom of the
impeachment inquiry
how democrats should carry it forward i
want to hear from you i'm on twitter at
d pacman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show and so yesterday i said i was going
to be live streaming on twitch
i ended up live streaming on youtube
yesterday tonight
i am live streaming on twitch at
twitch.tv
david pakman we'll be talking about this
and i hope to see you
there so i hate to have to break it to
you today and to start the show on such
a negative note
especially to my progressive audience
members but unless something changes
with a high likelihood donald trump is
very rapidly barreling towards
reelection in 2020
and this is why i've been very careful
not to make any statements when i report
about
oh you know georgia could conceivably be
in play texas could conceivably be in
play
uh there are a lot of uh ifs ands and
buts attached to that and before we get
into the issues based components of my
commentary today
let's just deal with the math quickly
because there are people who are just
putting way too much confidence
in the polling data that shows trump not
doing well in north carolina and georgia
and texas and trump's approval rating is
tanking
and then there are also people who just
don't believe me when i say that donald
trump
can get re-elected even despite a very
low
approval rating the reality is that what
we saw in 2004
is the case anytime you're trying to
unseat an incumbent president which is
it's really difficult donald uh trump uh
certainly very different than george w
bush in many ways but as difficult as it
was to remove bush in 2004
ultimately not being removed of course
even someone as
malignantly ignorant and acutely
narcissistic as donald trump will be
difficult
to remove now from a mathematical
perspective when half the country
doesn't vote
and you have an electoral college system
that systemically
favors republicans in all of the ways
that we've talked about before
donald trump's 36 or 38 or 40 percent
approval rating
can easily get him reelected now i've
said before
you can construct the math such that
it's possible to get reelected even with
27 approval
and it's true but if you disagree with
me about that or you think it's an
exaggeration
it's not even worth arguing about
because trump's approval rating isn't
that low and there's no indication
it's going to go that low so with the
math piece
out of the way let's look at what
democrats are doing so far
bearing in mind that we're still in the
pre-primary phase
democrats need to run good campaigns
with progressive ideas that are popular
of course but democrats also need to at
least
somewhat appeal to red state voters and
moderates in purple states on the issues
that clearly matter right now as i've
said before
as a strategy get out the vote is much
more powerful
than arguing with trumpists but
it still makes sense to at least stake
out
positions generally speaking that will
be reasonable to some fraction
of those moderate republican voters now
there's a necessary disclaimer here
i'm being strategic here i'm not talking
about what i like
and what my politics are i'm talking
about
winning 2020. think about immigration
first
it's disgusting what's happening at the
border
it's a real humanitarian crisis but most
of the conversations that democratic
candidates are having
are ridiculous and debate moderators are
hugely to blame for this as i've talked
about before
what's happening with the discussion
around deportations
on the right is an absolute fantasy
right i mean
we're not going to deport 12 million
people who are in the united states
illegally nor would we
want to deport the 12 million people
that are in the united states illegally
if people are committing violent crimes
and they're here illegally okay they're
now you're talking about people that it
makes sense to deport
but the reality is that there are
multiple industries that depend on these
undocumented immigrants including
agriculture
including the restaurant industry and
they're a hugely positive influence on
our society both economically and
culturally
from any number of standpoints
from an american dream standpoint from a
work ethic standpoint in basically every
way that we can imagine
almost all of these undocumented
immigrants are actually a positive force
here in the united states at the same
time
democrats need to throw a bone to
centrist and republican voters
around the need to have a defensible
border a defended
border i've already debunked the idea of
the wall endless times and democrats
don't need to
you know pretend to be aggressive
neocons on the wall or
even dabble with the xenophobic or
racist stuff but
something needs to be done to just
merely get on the record to republican
voters that democratic candidates
understand the concerns
there will be a defensible border and no
one is advocating for
open borders because they're going to
try to smear all the democratic
candidates
as being in favor of open borders when
of course that's not the case
it should just be made clear that no one
is advocating for open borders
because that's the truth but a little
more is going to need to be done and
said
if we don't want to have the exact
repetition of the 2016 election this
isn't controversial right
every country in the world that is an
interesting and appealing place for
people to come to from other countries
is going to have a defended border this
wouldn't change under a democratic
president
let's just like go five percent further
in making that clear but like i've said
before
we end up with all of this you know
raise your hands if you'd give
undocumented immigrants health care
even if that's a morally correct
position to take
it's a losing position if that becomes
the focus in the national election and
democrats need to make damn sure
that that doesn't actually become the
focus no matter what
debate moderators are going to try to do
okay let's talk about farmers and the
midwest
which we've been talking about for
months at this point in time
you have farmers in the midwest who are
aware that it's donald trump's tariffs
that have been a disaster for them
but merely saying i will reverse the
tariffs as many democratic candidates
have been saying
is not going to convince a lifelong
midwestern republican
to vote for a democrat and i've said
this before when we hear about all of
these
trump voters in the midwest who are
angry with trump or disapprove of trump
or are farmers and recognize that trump
is ruining their businesses
that doesn't mean that you're going to
go out and vote for a democrat in
november of 2020. lifelong republicans
who don't approve of trump aren't
necessarily voting
for joe biden or bernie sanders or
elizabeth warren
so something more needs to be done there
and it generally relates to the economic
anxieties of middle america
that hillary clinton didn't do a good
job of addressing in an appropriate
enough way
this is just the reality i'm not saying
the narrative about disadvantaged white
people
is based in any reality it's ridiculous
what i am
saying is that without addressing some
of these issues in a smart way
trump gets reelected period this gets me
to the distraction attempts that have
been very successful by the right
when donald trump generates a firestorm
around whether this or that person
is racist or whether a comment was
racist or whatever
these are important issues but they are
not
issues that are going to get swing state
voters
to abandon donald trump or motivate
anyone to get out and vote
if they see an endless focus and debate
over
whether this or that comment was racist
as an example
now i know that there are people on the
left who won't like this
but it's just the reality and then
unfortunately i spoke a year ago about
my desire for this not to happen
democrats and their supporters are
starting to slam each other
in a way that could be self-destructive
and just help
donald trump we are seeing i'm going in
no particular order here
we're seeing a rise of a no biden no way
contingent and i agree
that joe biden is not a progressive but
i also remember
all those people who said in 2016 who
cares hillary would be the same as trump
and of course they couldn't have been
more wrong look at the supreme court
look at the 25 percent of judges that
donald trump
has appointed and we're reminded every
day
that and the geopolitical belligerence
and now
trying to collude with enforcing
collusion with another country ukraine
we'll talk about that later
could not have been more different from
hillary clinton so that's a concern
then we have the growing group of bernie
supporters
focusing their ire on elizabeth warren
even mass unsubscribing from my youtube
channel last week when i pointed out hey
in 60 of recent polls warren has
surpassed bernie into second place
this group claiming warren is a tool of
the establishment disguised to appear
progressive and i'm
a shill merely for mentioning poll
results bernie and warren are not the
same
that's clear but that is another
contingent
that is potentially self-destructive and
it's getting to the point where it could
be damaging in the general election
the tulsi people i've already talked
about andrew yang's followers who
although relatively small mathematically
are getting extremely angry with just
like everything every anything that
happens they're absolutely furious about
then you've got biden supporters who are
falling
for the often repeated right-wing
talking points about
bernie and warren are extreme
they are radical they're too far left
they're even talking about the term
socialism that's the contingent of
biden supporters that's terrible
this is the type of stuff that will
propel donald trump to re-election
because it feeds narratives that are not
useful to the left so i'm not saying
this because i'm looking to attack
a particular candidate or the supporters
of a particular candidate this isn't
even about
particular candidates this is merely
pragmatism we saw what happened in 2016.
and unless we prevent these things i'm
mentioning from getting completely out
of control
it's going to happen again and we'll
have four more years of trump now there
are people in the audience who would
rather
have four more years of trump than
whoever you don't like from the
democratic primary right there are
people who would say
burn it all down let trump do whatever
he wants to do
because it's better than having whoever
it is that's running in the democratic
primary
i just disagree with that as a strategy
i think that the more we look at history
the more we realize
that what has worked historically is not
uh foregoing small changes we could make
right now
with the idea of eventually burning it
all down and building it back up in a
perfect image of what is perfectly
aligned
with our political ideology that's not
the way it's worked in the last
however many however however many years
you consider to be modern politics
that's simply not a strategy that's
worked so i'm open to having my mind
changed if you think you can convince me
that the let trump have another four
years burn it all down and then we'll be
in a much better position
for 2024 mentality if you want to try to
convince me of that
i'm more than open to hearing from you
but it's not something that i see backed
by history
it's not something i see backed by logic
and it's not something that seems like
the right approach
let me know what you think i'm open to
having my mind changed about
all of this but i am increasingly
concerned because i don't want to see
another four years of donald trump yeah
i know it'd be great for the show
but i care about the country even more
than that uh
and i want to hear from you if you
disagree with me i'm on twitter at d
pacman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show
i told you yesterday that the trump
ukraine
biden fiasco is going to become all
about the transcript of the
20 july 2019 phone call between trump
and the ukrainian president and that
this is a distraction
and exactly as we discussed yesterday
the white house
uh is now going to be putting out a
transcript of that phone call now the
white house has a history
of doctoring transcripts the quid pro
quo
is unlikely to be evident just from one
phone calls transcript anyway and the
most
important part of all of this is that a
whistleblower report
is being suppressed the whistleblower
report
about all of this is the most important
thing
not the transcript so now that donald
trump plans to release the transcript
we need to understand that it will be
exactly what we discussed yesterday
it's going to be the bar letter 2.0 okay
so to reset once again in case the
details are becoming murky the idea here
the claim is that joe biden meddled in
the ukrainian judicial system to help
his son
now this is a conspiracy theory for
which there is no evidence
and i debunked it yesterday and i'm not
going to waste your time with it again
today
but what donald trump then did is he
went and he pressured the ukrainian
president reportedly eight times
to open an investigation into biden in
order to smear him and trump
has admitted to talking to the ukrainian
president about joe biden he's admitted
that
joe biden's alleged corruption was a
topic of discussion
during the phone call with the ukrainian
president and his lawyer rudy giuliani
also admitted this on live television
and donald trump withheld between 250
million and 400 million
dollars in military aid to ukraine
understood to be over the biden smear
requests
but that part has not been definitively
confirmed
so now we hear trump is going to release
a
transcript of the call from july 2019
with the ukrainian president
but please understand what's going to
happen here and i told you yesterday
it will be just like the bar letter
trump is going to release a transcript
that he thinks will help him trump lies
about everything he lies about the size
of his crowds
he lies about the size of his whatever
he lies about
uh his own intelligence he lies about
the weather on inauguration day he lies
about
everything so the transcript that is
released
will be muddy enough that it won't be
obvious and over corruption and quid pro
quo
and that lack of uh brazen
and obvious corruption in that one phone
call
will then be used by trump and his
defenders to say see look i told you
there's nothing to see here they will
claim trump
is exonerated by the transcript
we need the whistleblower report but it
needs to be given directly to congress
the trump administration should not be
allowed to review and modify the report
before it's given to congress which is
the direction things are going in right
now
we need the whistleblower to testify
before congress
anything like what is being alleged here
this pressure on the ukrainian president
it would be set up with much more
than just a single phone call in july of
2019 and what we need to do
is not allow donald trump to distract
with
the transcript whatever form that
transcript
ultimately takes any whistleblower
report released by the white house
must be treated as unreliable and
incomplete
period it will be edited it will be
misleading it has to be treated as such
by corporate media
we will see if they actually do treat it
that way but
this is now layer upon layer of
obfuscation
and misdirection you have initially uh
you have a whistleblower who came
forward and said i want to blow the
whistle about this
you then had that covered with the joe
biden conspiracy theory which is hey
uh joe biden was there specifically to
make sure that his son
doesn't get uh doesn't have a problem
because he's working with this ukrainian
gas company
blah blah blah we debunked that
yesterday then on top of that
is the white house coming out and
actually copying to some elements of
what's being alleged about aid being
withheld although they don't agree
as to why it was done etc and then now
layer four
on top of this these are just
distraction layers stacked one on top of
the other
is that the transcript is going to be
released and maybe the whistleblower
report in some
edited form is going to be released
we've got to cut through like three
layers of bs here
to get what ultimately is most important
which is a whistleblower report
that is being suppressed period
we are going to be making a number of
posts about this story
including a poll to the show's instagram
page
which is at david pakman show make sure
you're following the show on instagram
and while you're there follow me on
instagram as well
at david.pakman we will take a quick
break and be back
with so much more right after this